rykov who's fighting for his baseball
life as well four shutout innings
against the braves on june 21st his last
start not a lot of help in the field
five unearned runs
and adrianza is hit with a breaking ball
on a two-strike count and the braves
will take that break
as adrianza is aboard to start the game
thank you very much adrianza was running
he is again pitches inside two on nobody
out a hit batsman and a walk
and the bases are loaded
[Applause]
2-2 coming and riley hits one down a
third a chance for two coming home his
vr gets the force there and that's all
had a chance to turn two if he had gone
to second
now you got dansby up a chance too with
one out to do some damage one one pitch
swung on and lined bear down the left
field line it'll roll all the way to the
wall and into the corner this will score
two
first to third for riley a two rbi
double for dansby two nothing braves
and he pelted that one over the head of
vr and into the corner to get two in
a great way to capitalize and at least
the braves did not spoil this golden
opportunity we talked about
el monte pulls one down to first handled
by alonso and that retires the side so
icoff does as well as he can to limit
the damage now we go to the second
inning at a very windy city field all of
a sudden
and adrianza takes ball four that's the
third walk
make this man pay already 42 pitches
and ozzie hits one a mile high to deep
right did he keep it fair
he did into the upper deck
a first pitch mammoth home run from ozzy
all bees and the braves get two more
with two outs it's four to nothing
[Music]
look at that yeah almost white line but
he pulls those hands in beautifully
and just keeps it inside that foul pole
you know the mets have some catching up
to do against a guy that they don't hit
very well
that's smack to left center field by
conforto back goes her radio i can't
make the catch then florida want his way
to second he's going gonna take a turn
and hold up there
so michael conforto getting on the first
pitch from charlie morton and driving it
over the head of radio for the men's
first base runner of the night
swing and a miss
filthy breaking ball for strikeout
number two
check of the runner the one-two pitch
swing animus another curveball strikeout
for charlie morton he strands conforto
who has the mets lone hit garrett icon
right back out there to start the third
tops this one up though
in foul ground
wind grabs it the r stays with it and
makes the catch tough play for vr
but he made it for the first down nice
play dough balls in a strike i cough to
almonte
and that one is hit high in the air
toward left center field that ball is
carrying off the top of the wall
and it is a home run
abraham almonte with another two out two
run homer and the braves are blowing out
the mets it's six to nothing see he got
a split
up in the zone el monte stayed through
it right off the m
bottom of the third at city field the
mitts have seen jared ikoff give up two
runs in each inning so far
and he gets a nice bunt down and morton
will go to first with it freddie got in
his way
still made the play
and nimmo takes the curveball down for
ball four and he cooks as a walk
one one pitch
is on the ground nice pick riley second
base one that's all atlanta gets good
play by austin reilly to get the force
out so now alonso with first and third
and two down
that's poked the other way a base hit
for alonso and the midsole get their
first run
he's looking away
and doesn't try to hit the three-run
home run
nicely done pete
charlie board to lead things off
[Applause]
and charlie morton has a base head
deep right field that ball is off the
wall
and the braves have them second and
third with nobody out
and they'll intentionally walk freddie
freeman
that's too bad for freddie yeah i liked
his chances there now they're loaded
with one down for austin reilly
and there's a first pitch bullet
to
wow into the second deck
austin riley has hit a grand slam
and the braves are blowing them out now
you talked about making adjustments know
you want to get a ball up in the zone
that's what austin riley did something
he could drive to the outfield
and this one absolutely hammered it out
of the stadium
icoff trying to run it in first pitch
i don't remember right-hand hitters
going up there at
it
does not happen very much put it that
way the ncd has in the pitch to steven
vote
and vote goes down in the chain jump
good pitch by diaz for the second out
almonte flies one to shallow left and
comes drury just into the game and he
gets there to make the catch that
retires the side but the riley grand
slam opens it up for atlanta 10-1 in the
fourth bottom of the fifth inning in all
atlanta tonight charlie morton the
beneficiary
toward the hole past riley and swanson
can't get the handle and drury's got an
infield hit
the 1-2 to mcneil hit high in the air
deep to right center aradia back at the
wall he jumps it's gone home run jeff
mcneal he's just extended his hitting
streak to 14 consecutive games his fifth
home run of the year and the braves lead
is cut to 10-3
fastball right down the middle belt high
and watch him clear his hips here
[Applause]
and he is swinging a good bat
austin reilly a grand slam what a road
trip he's having
another high fly ball crushed belted off
the facade of the second deck
it's a two-homer game for riley
well he only hit that one 420.
[Applause]
gets the ball on the inner half
[Applause]
full extension and knows it 19th homer
of the year now
56 ribbies
pablo might as well keep that thing on
mitts are trailing the braves 12-3
brandon drury will be the batter now
drury gets a hold of one to left field
back rose almonte looking up and it's
out of here
brandon drury goes deep
a two-run shot for drury his third of
the year
and now it's 12-5 atlanta
i think he's done just about everything
asked of him when he's been here he's
just run into roster issues
effective as a pinch hitter he can play
a multiple
multitude of positions
you know it's nice always to have that
one guy on your bench that's got home
run pop
they're gonna expect you to win it
leaping grab by albies that's a big
second out
little guy showing some ups off the end
of the bat
timed it perfect
josh tomlin will come on and try to get
the final three outs
first two hits of the series for alonso
have come tonight
and this one lifted toward left but not
deep enough
the braves beat the mets 12-5 they lead
this series two games to one they pull
to within four games of the division
leaders